[Music]
well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of the guardian papakura and the
political editor of the sun Harry Cole
with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you as ever
let's take a look shall we at the front
pages starting with the Daily Mail small
boats crisis they say we will push the
human rights laws to the Limit that's
the front page of the mail as it looks
at the government's plans to introduce
tough measures to tackle small boat
arrivals in the UK the front of the eye
also leads on the story its headline
sunac plans to stop Channel migrants may
be unworkable Tories warn him
The Daily Telegraph continues its
lockdown files this time looking at
Plans by Matt Hancock the headline block
funds for MPS who don't toe the line on
lockdown
families double tragedy reads the
headline of the Metro as they examine
the Fallout of a devastating car crash
in South Wales
the guardian reports on an investigation
into methane leaks into the atmosphere
front page of the financial times looks
at plans for a meeting between taiwan's
President and the U.S House speaker
which will take place in California
and the
gongfather is the headline of the Delhi
star checking I could read it amid
reports that former prime minister Boris
Johnson has nominated his father for a
Knighthood
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you listen
to our guests let's head straight to
Pippa and Harry welcome to both of you
lots of coverage then on the plans that
we'll hear tomorrow about how to stop
these Small Boat Crossings including
double page spread in the times storm
clouds ahead for a law that aims to curb
Channel Crossings and Harry there's no
doubt that this is you know broken
previous administrations and may well be
difficult to you for for Rishi sunak but
the sound of it is going to give it a
good go tell us more
absolutely in fact the prime minister is
written in the sun tomorrow and he says
just that he says that our readers at
the British public have been promised
all sorts of things before but haven't
lived up to expectations they've been
promised legislation that's going to fix
things bit of a dig there pretty Patel
actually and Boris Johnson whose own
attempt at this didn't go very well and
there's still sort of logged bogged up
in the courts with the Rwanda scheme but
he's saying look we are going to push
this to the Limit essentially this bill
is going to be highly controversial for
the first time and I'm sorry to get a
little bit techy here it's going to have
something called a section 19B order in
it which is essentially an
acknowledgment for ministers which says
we don't really know if this breaks
international law we don't really know
whether this actually rubs up they're
saying pushes up against our commitments
we've made to the European Convention of
Human Rights and could conceivably break
that now that is going to go down very
badly with the very well-heeled very
vocal Army of lawyers open borders Act
this and I suspect large parts of the
left-wing media so it's going to be a
very very very Punchy day tomorrow I
think yes well I'll come back to that
double page spread in the times which
has a lot of detail but let's pick up on
that in the Daily Mail shall we we will
push human rights laws to the Limit
um as Harry said is that partly where
he's got to go and speak to macro on
Friday what's he hoping to achieve in
that meeting later this week then Peppa
so this is going to be the first
bilateral Summit in on French soil since
2018 after a fairly sort of uh turbulent
few years of relationship between
Britain and France amidst all the brexit
wars
um amidst Boris Johnson's perhaps more
belligerent approach uh towards our
French neighbors uh than Rishi sinak who
has been Keen from the off to have a
much more diplomatic relationship with
them the role of the French when it
comes to the human rights angle of it is
is the role of All European European
countries that uh that are sort of
subscribed it
um that what really what this summit's
going to be about though is about what
more the French can do on French beaches
to try and prevent some of those people
trafficking gangs bringing across boats
in the first place we have reached a
deal with a French last year uh but I
think it's about 65 million pounds
um that we paid them in order to step up
Patrols
um to stop some of those gangs getting
people over uh they report patrols were
doubled there was going to be drones
used various other sort of enforcement
measures but uh as we saw with some of
the figures last year for the numbers of
people coming over the channel That
despite the fact that that substantially
more uh people were prevented from
Crossing I think the number went from
about 40 000 to about 80 000 were
prevented coming over or sorry 40 to 80
I should say of attempted Crossings were
prevented by the French the the numbers
still kept coming and so as as part of
the sort of the bigger picture
um for dealing with uh the government's
plan to deal with
um this issue is is of course the French
and it's a key part is a key part of it
so having tried for years under previous
administrations to sort of have a much
more sort of uh relationship
with the French and trying to sort of
try and sort of you know criticizing
them and I'm hesitant to use for
bullying but you know pushing them to do
more to stop them to to do more to stop
the boats uh sunak is trying a very
different track of trying more more
diplomatic approach so let's see whether
it works I think we'll we wouldn't
obviously know until Friday and
afterwards what the french has signed up
to but uh macron and he do seem to have
sort of hit it off uh more than some of
our previous previous leaders so we'll
see what they managed to come up with
yes and interestingly all sorts of
international conversations taking place
just hearing that the front uh secretary
James cleverley has spoken to his
counterpart in France as well uh helping
prepare as they said for the 36th Franco
British Summit to be held on the 10th of
March and also we hear that the Prime
Minister has had a call with the
president of Rwanda uh president Paul
kagami they discussed the UK Rwanda
migration partnership and our joint
efforts to break the business model of
criminal people's Smugglers and address
humanitarian issues
um that came as a leak suggested that
the first Rwanda flights might not
happen until March 2024 Harry sir all of
this is long-term staff that will be
challenged in the courts and will not
deliver the instant result possibly that
the government seems to be after
well the best case scenario for yeah as
you say for um or Rwanda flight is
Christmas at the earliest that's if they
win every every sort of part of their
appeal the appeal process the
government's already won in the high
court let's make this very clear the
high court has ruled that the Rwanda
policy is legal however that is being
challenged in the court of appeal it's a
debate about whether they whether it's a
split result it then goes to the Supreme
Court and and so on and so on what I
think tomorrow's legislation I think is
trying to do and it's going to take a
number of months to get it through the
house of government so I hear Whispers
that actually they might start voting on
that bill pretty soon as soon as next
week in fact try and keep up some of the
momentum on this
um look they're trying to make this
water type this bill was promised in in
the new year and then it was promised in
sort of you know as it sort of
performance before the new year then the
new year now it's it's I think
officially spring although it doesn't
feel like it outside they've really
worked a long time again making sure
this is actually not going to be in its
you know as sort of as sort of um sort
of holy if that makes sense woolly as
previous attempts where activists
lawyers were able to pick apart with the
help of uh you know the help of
Charities and campaigners holes in this
bill I think they're going to try and
keep this very very very tightly worded
or so they promise in order to try and
avoid some of these legal plays and as
we have it Parliament is Sovereign in
this country if they change the law and
clear up some of those loopholes that
are being exploited at the moment there
should the hope is they will speed this
up but however I mean even the the
greatest of optimists if you're back in
this policy think that it's going to
happen anytime soon and what you're
heading into is 2024 an election year
um it is Sun Pierce tomorrow the Prime
Minister you don't normally hear him
directly call out kirst armor and labor
and the left as a sort of block but he
does it in the sun tomorrow and he says
look I've got a plan this is what I want
to do what's your plan you can't just
say you know put two fingers in your ear
and say more money for France more money
for France that hasn't worked they've
given a quarter of a billion over the
last since 2014. something's got to give
here so I think he is actually while
also being seen to be trying to calm
down on it setting up a bit of an
election battle into next year to
basically say to the country look we're
trying to fix it we may not have been
able to do it overnight and no one can
do it overnight but at least we're
trying to do something whether the
voters have heard enough already made
their minds up and think here storm is
the man to you know who just a year ago
two two years ago sorry was signing
letters against deportations is the man
to fix UK borders well that's going to
be an election issue yeah interesting um
the eye says that critics have won the
stop the boats pledge is unworkable as
one the UK lacks capacity to detain tens
of thousands of Asylum Seekers and may
struggle to find countries to take
deportees we don't have agreements with
very many countries at all on that
um The Guardian your paper
um suggesting that swella brothman the
Home Secretary when she speaks in the
Commons tomorrow we'll ask for the
proposed law to be applied from the
moment she stands up uh Pippa which is
interesting in itself is it not so you
know will the message get through will
it work will it will it stop the trade
if you like and will it put people off
crossing the Channel all questions
Nobody Knows the answer to
yeah I mean there's various aspects to
this there is the sort of the domestic
political one
um to uh which Tory MPS are obviously
very keen to have something that they
can tell people when they bring up
um this issue and the doorsteps and for
lots of them it's one of the you know
voters priorities when they when they
speak to them uh particularly in some of
the the sort of vegetable seats that the
Tories need to hang on to at the next
election so the sort of domestic
political
um uh solution if you like um but then
there's also the and the fact that that
obviously can be used as Harry mentioned
as a sort of a dividing line with labor
ahead of the next ahead of the next
election or at least the toys want to
try and and do that but there's also
sort of the reality of the situation on
the ground and the fact that there are
um there's huge backlog in
um in processing Asylum Asylum uh
claimants that are ready in the country
um and that people you mentioned the
capacity issue there on the front of the
Ayanna well you know this is actually I
think 107 from having open to
conservative MPS this is actually as
much of an issue as people coming over
the
um over the channel is is the fact that
local hotels and holiday camps and uh
student accommodation are being used to
house uh some of these some of these uh
Asylum Seekers that are that are
awaiting their their claims being made
and until the government can get that
number down and it is it's trying you
know is trying to know but it's still
there's a huge number of talking about
tens and tens of thousands of people
um then then I think the historian peas
are still going to see some complaints
um on the doorstep you know I think it
was something this astonishing figure
I'm sure Harry will correct me if I get
this if you get this wrong but it's
something like of all the claimants last
year only four percent
um were processed which really isn't
good enough the system needs to speed up
substantially so this capacity issue
there there's also as you mentioned the
returns agreements that we don't have a
return to agreement with France at the
moment there was one that existed when
remembered the European Union but of
course that wasn't that wasn't working
effectively and France is reluctant to
um to come to a bilateral agreement it
will want to have some sort of some
pan-european agreement when it comes to
returns and then we've also have the
aspect that the the returns agreements
with with countries like Albania which
is which is um being set up but then the
deal with Rwanda which is only currently
for sort of two or three hundred
individuals
presumably as this as this uh this
scheme continues if it continues if it
gets off the ground eventually and then
the government will want to increase
that but Rwanda will also have a limit
on capacity of the numbers of people
that it can take over there and so you
sort of start to reach a point where you
you know you have to ask where are you
going to where you're going to put all
these people you're going to hold them
if you look if you don't want them to be
in the UK while you where you process
their claims uh so there's you know
there's lots of issues there Beyond this
sort of you know the legislation itself
uh about the existing problems that need
to be solved first and hope you will
hear a little bit more from
celebrotherman about how they how they
plan to deal with the existing backlog
how they plan to speed up processing and
how they managed to how the Numbers
number 10 suggest they want to do will
abide by international law when they do
all of this with the legislation and
just looking ahead and very quickly
Harry the times suggests
um starts talking about annual caps once
again
um Parliament will be given the power to
set an annual cap on Refugee numbers and
this is after ministers consult with
local authorities about how many
migrants they can take and then also
Rishi sunak plans for safe and legal
routes to deter people from making
dangerous Crossings the bit that many
people say have been lacking but I
wanted to ask you you know who's the
electorate for this if you talk about
this being a general election issue and
asking you to generalize no doubt but
you know which is the part of the
electorate that cares most about this
I think it's a wide range of the lecture
I think there's been too many attempts
to try and slightly patronizing and I'd
say incredibly snobbishly to suggest
this is somehow something that's only
going to appeal to the red wall uh
voters I think that's absolute nonsense
I think this affects anyone that that
has struggled to get a Hospital
appointment at places with their school
anyone that's tried to rent a hotel room
anywhere in England in the last year
where you know every single two three
four-star hotel any all over the country
appears to be blocked booked by the home
office driving up the prices of other
hotels in in in vast parts of the
country and then you've got to look at
anyone who cares about British
sovereignty and the idea that actually
you know basic government competence
there's no finer illustration of the
limit limited sort of influence of
government that they they can't do the
one thing they're meant to do top of the
list which is protect our country
protect our borders and you have a this
sort of bizarre scenes of of you know
we've been told we're going to take back
control but seemingly unable to T
because we can't control our Southern
borders so I think it's a wide range of
people that are infuriated by this and
polling shows that it is a number one
you know a very very high issue if not
number one for a lot of people
immigrations yeah we talked about the
op-ed in the Sun from the Prime Minister
um there's also an op-ed from sweller
brothman in the express these are her
words uh we must stop the boats and
that's what our bill will do no more
sticking plasters or shying away from
difficult decisions myself and the Prime
Minister have been working tirelessly to
ensure we have a bill that works we've
pushed the boundaries of international
law to solve the crisis we saw that on
the front page of the mail did we nod
um this is about ensuring that tens of
thousands of migrants each year are not
jumping the queue Millions more are
waiting to come to our Shores we have to
stop criminal gangs taking advantage of
people and putting them in danger by
coming across the channel if you come
here illegally it must be that you
cannot stay so that is the Home
Secretary we will hear from her tomorrow
but let's quickly go to the other story
I know you want to talk about
partygate Pippa a starmer is still
tight-lipped on partygate officials job
and when she was offered it as we heard
earlier and also that's in the Metro but
also in the financial times as well um
the top Civil Service Simon cases eyeing
a possible early exit so bring us up to
date with what we know and what needs to
happen now
well as we know uh kiisama has asked Sue
gray the senior civil servant to act as
his chief of staff with a very distinct
and discreet uh request to prepare help
the labor party prepare for government
she's not she wouldn't be doing any of
the sort of the political side of things
but this was this information was it was
last week it was
Lisa
um Joe Pike reported it and
um and rather sort of you know forced
forced Libra's hand uh after the cabinet
office confirmed I think Harry in fact
was first to report that the cabinet
office has confirmed it and then
um and then after that Libra did so we
had this this urgent question in the in
the House of Commons this morning quite
interestingly this afternoon uh quite
interestingly 14 different uh requests
had gone in for Urgent questions many of
them using exactly the same language
which is a device normally used by
number 10 or at least some sort of
orchestrated campaign presumably in this
case the Boris Johnson campaign
um and one of those was one of those was
picked it was it was it was very
specifically about civil service and
partiality and in fact anybody that
tried to sort of range off the the quite
defined
um the defined topic of of that and onto
sort of whether whether the particular
inquiry was biased a lot was very
quickly slapped on by the speaker uh but
during it Jeremy Quinn Who is the
cabinet office Minister who was
responding suggested that Sue gray may
have broken the Civil Service rules
already because there is a
responsibility to tell a Cooper which is
the body that runs business appointments
for civil servants and and from
ministers
um it has to give their approval that
they have to be informed before that is
announced now it's it's Libra kind of
slightly splitting hairs on this because
they say well we didn't break any rules
because we only confirmed it after it's
already been announced by um the cabin
office by Sue gray and others uh you
know whether whether a Cooper makes the
same judgment that those rules weren't
breached we'll have to see and certainly
it was it's not an official inquiry into
this but there are people at the cabinet
office looking to make sure that the
civil service code had been followed now
really this is a very kind of inside
politics Minister issue in the world are
actually going to be that caught up with
it all